this is one of the most challenging
times for government in a generation
government really needs to function
today
government needs to perform
it is
a matter of life and death
government operations
and wasting energy on distractions
is the last thing that state government
should be doing
and i cannot be the cause
of that
new york tough
means new york loving
and i love new york
and i love you
and everything i have ever done
has been motivated by that love
and i would never want to be unhelpful
in any way
and i think that given the circumstances
the best way i can help now
is if i step aside and let government
get back to governing
and therefore that's what i'll do
because i work
for you
and doing the right thing
is doing the right thing
for you
because as we say it's not about me
it's about we
kathy holcomb my lieutenant governor is
smart and competent
this transition must be seamless
we have a lot going on i'm very worried
about the delta variant
and so should you be
but she can come up to speed quickly and
my resignation will be effective in 14
days